Họng bốn dở nắm bị phút hôm nay một một tảng bệnh năm 2020,
tổ con tác thủ hội kể sát xa thông số năm,
phòng kể sát xa thông công an tỉnh lâm đồng,
ra chúng ta nguyễn sĩ triệu làm tổ chương,
đến hình tình chát trên đường vũ si Minh,
đảng qua xa quảng tỉnh, lâm đồng, xa quảng tỉnh,
vệnh đặc lập tỉnh đất nồng cú.
Hãy sai đăng dừng bên đường thì bất nổ phát hiện 2 vợ trong ág lộ Amen,
xin nămu nhìn chiến trăm chiến bí chính,
và chỉ lihi thị sông, xin năm 2020,
chú tại sát quảng tất, lâm đồng đặc ngọt,
chú đức tỉnh đất nồng cú, đáng ở cạnh chiếc xe máy.
Chị sông có biểu hiện đau bụt,
chuyến giả, lúc này, lực lượng cạnh xa xa thông yên chóng dùng xe đặc trung chờ anh miên
và chỉ xong đến bệnh vịt.
Hí bởi đến cộn bệnh vịt,
chỉ xong bất ngờ xin chào bệnh chia xe đặc trung của lượng cạnh xa xa thông.
Một cám mộ cạnh xa xa thông chức tiếp chờ vợ trong xị xong đến bệnh vệnh cho biết,
hí ổ chứ xe, anh em đồng bệnh chỉ xong của gắng đến bệnh vịt để xin con cho anh quan,
như không kiệt.
Chúng tôi rất mừng,
dù phải xin con chứ xe xe,
như mẹ con chỉ xong bệnh anh quan,
mẹ chọn con vô,
cạnh mộ cạnh xa xa thông nói.